[Musik]
festnahmen nach seilbahnunglück die
notbremsen der abgestürzten gondel waren
offenbar bewusst blockiert
angebote auch für kinder
der bundesgesundheitsminister sagt ja
die experten zögern ein diktator in rage
der machthaber von belarus lukaschenko
droht dem westen mit gegen sanktionen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend herzlich
willkommen bei den heute nachrichten an
diesem mittwoch an meiner seite
arbeitnehmern ein stimmwunder von mir
drei tage nach dem seilbahnunglück in
italien verfestigt sich ein verdacht der
nicht nur die angehörigen der opfer
fassungslos macht offenbar war die
gondel am lago maggiore vor ihrem
absturz technisch manipuliert worden
wohl eine maßnahme der betreiber um sie
trotz mängeln weiter einsetzen zu können
und das hieße 14 menschen mussten
sterben weil andere ganz bewusst ein
risiko in kauf genommen haben es gab
drei festnahmen
annette hilsenbeck blumen an der
trauerhalle in verbania wo die opfer des
seilbahnunglück es liegen noch immer
kommen menschen die ihre anteilnahme
zeigen tief erschüttert sind von dem was
geschah in der nacht hatten die
ermittler den chef und zwei
verantwortliche mitarbeiter des
seilbahnbetreiber sparrow wie amon
tarone festgenommen diese haben laut
polizei die notbremse der seilbahn
deaktiviert absichtlich wurde eine
vorrichtung eingesetzt die
umgangssprachlich gabel genannt wird sie
verhindert dass die notbremse aktiviert
wird falls das nun endlich was hat nach
dem reißen des kabels zur tragödie
geführt
normalerweise greifen notbremsen
automatisch sobald das zugseil reißt die
kabine wird dann an den tragseilen
fixiert mit einer gabel kann verhindert
werden dass die bremsbacken sich
schließen sie blockiert also die bremse
folge als am sonntag das zugseil der
bahn kurz unterhalb der bergstation
reist was die gondel ungebremst
talabwärts gegen einen pfeiler und
stürzt dann in die tiefe
die beschuldigten sollen die notbremsen
manipuliert haben weil diese seit wochen
störungen des seilbahn betriebes
verursacht hatten
eine reparatur hätte einen längeren
ausfall der seilbahn bedeutet das war
ein bewusster akt denn das erforderte
das aktive einbauen eines teiles und das
passiert nicht zufällig
kazuo der einzige überlebende ein
das war ein kleiner ok vor dem neuen
corona gipfel morgen ist eine
kontroverse entbrannt und zwar um die
frage ob man kinder und jugendliche
schon bald in die impfkampagne mit
einbeziehen soll
so wie es der gesundheitsminister
befürwortet im gegensatz zur stiko der
ständigen impfkommission die wand man
wisse bisher noch zu wenig über mögliche
nebenwirkungen der impfung bei kindern
bei den erwachsenen haben inzwischen
40,6 prozent eine erste dosis erhalten
14,8 prozent sind vollständig geimpft
ab dem siebten juni fällt die
priorisierung weg das heißt alle ab 16
jahren können sich dann um einen termin
bemühen
bleibt die frage was ist mit kindern und
jugendlichen ab zwölf jahren florian
coaching fanny wird heute gleich zwei
mal geimpft einmal gegen tetanus und
einmal gegen hpv dass die 13 jährige
möglicherweise schon bald auch die
korona impfung bekommen könnte findet
sie gut genau wie ihre mutter
ich gehe davon aus dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit größer ist das wenn
sie geimpft ist dass es ihr nützt als
dass es ihr schadet impfen oder nicht
impfen viele eltern treibt das thema der
zeitung in ihrer erfurter
kinderarztpraxis stößt bei wie franke
beckmann auf viel skepsis und sorgen was
sie auch nachvollziehen kann
die masse der kinder trägt ja nicht das
risiko schwer an coop 19 zu erkranken
hier muss wirklich eine große risiko
nutzen abwägung sein welches risiko hat
das kind schwer zu erkranken
und was ist der benefit fürs kind einer
solchen impfung
doch das können selbst experten noch
nicht mit endgültiger sicherheit sagen
noch wisse man zu wenig über mögliche
impfnebenwirkungen gerade weil es an
langzeitstudien fehler und die datenlage
noch zu dünn sei ob es eine generelle
impfempfehlung geben wird das halte ich
nicht für sehr wahrscheinlich
erstmal ist nun aber die europäische
arzneimittelbehörde am zug
erwartet wird dass sie in den kommenden
tagen grünes licht gibt für den
impfstoff für zwölf bis 15 jähriger die
bundesregierung will dann wie
angekündigt allen ab 12 jahren bis ende
august ein impfangebot machen aber es
wird definitiv keine verpflichtung zur
impfung geben und dann kann jeder wie
gesagt im lichte von empfehlung die
entscheidung für sich treffen
die entscheidung bleibt also bei eltern
und kindern die sicherlich dankbar sind
für kinderärzte wie frank beckmann die
ihn mit einem individuellen rat zur
seite stehen
er beherrscht dieses thema das impfen
von kindern auch den coruna gipfel von
bund und ländern morgen container
banerjee also es wird sicherlich nicht
das einzige thema sein denn es gibt sehr
viel organisatorisches zu besprechen der
impfpass steht auf der tagesordnung die
frage der auffrischungsimpfungen die ab
dem herbst dann fällig werden und auch
liefermengen bei impfstoffen das alles
wird sicherlich besprochen werden aber
tatsächlich wird das impfen von kindern
und jugendlichen breiten raum einnehmen
in der diskussion vor allem weil sehr
viele fragen offen sind zum beispiel ab
wann soll denn ein solches angebot
gelten wer soll eigentlich diese
impfungen vornehmen und vor allem woher
soll der zusätzliche impfstoff kommen
gibt es denn nochmal oben drauf vom bund
oder muss der woanders abgeknapst werden
und wirkt sich das dann auf andere
menschen aus
die bisher gehofft hatten dass sie
möglichst bald einen impftermin bekommen
also da gibt es von länderseite an den
bund noch viele fragen und
gesprächsbedarf morgen ab 14 uhr möchte
man da die köpfe zusammenstecken
vielen dank stark unter der band
erstmals seit vergangenen oktober ist
die sieben tage ins tendenz unter 50
gefallen auf bundesweit 46,8 allerdings
oder über pfingsten weniger getestet und
es wurden weniger daten übermittelt das
robert koch institut meldet 2626
neuinfektionen
das sind gut 8000 400 weniger als vor
einer woche
270 todesfälle kamen hinzu
die sinkenden infektionszahlen machen
hoffnungen vielleicht können wir ja
schon bald wieder kinos theater konzerte
oder andere kulturereignisse besuchen
veranstalter müssen jetzt planen und
vorbereiten um ihr finanzielles risiko
zu begrenzen stellt die regierung nun
2,5 milliarden euro bereit
das geld soll fließen wenn weniger
zuschauer kommen dürfen als nötig wären
oder veranstaltungen ganz abgesagt
werden müssen
ein ganz anderes thema jetzt
es sind zahlen die eine erschreckende
gesellschaftliche realität beleuchten
laut kriminalstatistik werden immer mehr
fälle sexualisierter gewalt gegen kinder
aufgedeckt um mehr als 50 prozent stieg
im vergangenen jahr die zahl der
verfahren wegen der verbreitung von
filmen oder bildern die sexuellen
missbrauch von kindern zeigen wird dass
spiekermann eine beratungsstelle in
erfurt für kinder und jugendliche in not
35 fälle pro woche betreuen sie hier
der andrang ist groß also was wirklich
wie viele viele themen sind ist sexuelle
gewalt sowohl wirklich körperlich im
realen leben als auch ganz häufig
sexualisiertes schreiben in
irgendwelchen messenger diensten gewalt
gegen kinder nimmt zu hat das mit den
corona beschränkungen zu tun
die experten sagen die datenlage sei
nicht eindeutig ein zusammenhang nicht
ausgeschlossen
auch durch verbesserte arbeit der
polizeibehörden wird das ausmaß im netz
immer sichtbarer bilder sexueller gewalt
gibt es massenhaft von 2009/10 bis 2020
ein anstieg um 53 prozent
es scheint so zu sein dass wir in diesem
feld wirklich ein kipp punkt erreicht
haben und deswegen muss deutschland
wirklich im kampf gegen sexualisierte
gewalt jetzt handeln polizeiliche
ermittlungen darf nicht kollabieren es
brauche dringend mehr personal ab 2022
ändert sich die rechtslage in
deutschland anbieter sozialer netzwerke
müssen nach hinweisen strafbares
material an polizeibehörden melden der
chef des bundeskriminalamts appelliert
anbieten das gilt für uns alle ford
werden wachsam zu sein verantwortung zu
übernehmen
anzeige erstatten wo immer die hinweise
haben auf strafbare handlungen an
kindern das thema messe ganz oben auf
die politische agenda der unabhängige
beauftragte für fragen des sexuellen
kindesmissbrauchs geht davon aus dass in
jeder schulklasse ein bis zwei
schülerinnen oder schüler sexueller
gewalt ausgesetzt sind
wichtige verhandlungen mit den eu
partnern am bundestag vorbei
das darf die regierung nicht hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht entschieden
anlass war ein eu gipfel zur
griechenlandrettung 2015
damals hatte finanzminister schäuble ein
mögliches ausscheiden griechenlands aus
dem euro ins spiel gebracht der
bundestag so die richter hätte aber
schon vor dem gipfel erfahren müssen
dass die regierung mit einer solchen
position in die verhandlungen geht die
festnahme eines belarussischen bloggers
sorgt weiter für heftige internationale
kritik machthaber alexander lukaschenko
verteidigt die erzwungenen
zwischenlandung jetzt als eine art
rettungsanker
die ryanair maschine war am sonntag auf
dem weg von athen in die litauische
hauptstadt vilnius wegen einer
angeblichen bombendrohung und begleitet
von einem belarussischen kampfjet wurde
sie nach minsk umgeleitet axel sturm
darius pokals kess war an bord des
ryanair flug nach vilnius war dabei der
zwangs landung in minsk
zunächst dachte er das flugzeug habe
technische probleme
irgendwann haben sie uns gesagt wir
sollen unsere sachen nehmen und das
flugzeug verlassen
das hat sehr lange gedauert wir standen
in einer schlange weil sie nur fünf
leute gleichzeitig von bord gelassen
haben
alle hatten sie offenbar nicht die bälle
russischen geheimdienstmitarbeiter
obwohl es angeblich eine bombendrohung
gab heute wissen wir es ging wohl um ihn
um roman protosevich den festgenommenen
oppositionellen dessen anwälte auch
heute nicht zu ihm durften dem in
belarus 15 jahre haft oder schlimmeres
ton
es gibt immer wieder politische
gefangene die in der haft sterben die
bedingungen in den gefängnissen sind
sehr hart hart dürfte auch der umgang
mit ihr seien sie ist angeblich die
freundin von brad pitt und gesteht jetzt
wie er wohl auch vermutlich unter zwang
ich arbeite für den telegrammen kanal
cerna jack niger der private
informationen über sicherheitsbeamte
veröffentlicht präsident lukaschenko
sagt der westen führe krieg gegen sein
land und droht mit gegen sanktionen ich
habe an die sicherheit des landes
gedacht
verstehen sie diese einfache sache wenn
es eine bombe gegeben hätte und
terroristen das flugzeug gesprengt
hätten hätten wir nichts mehr tun können
die kritik aus dem ausland auch aus
deutschland am vorgehen von minsk ebbt
nicht ab
syrien ist ein wenig aus dem blickfeld
der welt geraten heute finden dort
präsidentenwahlen statt eine pseudo
demokratische fassade für die diktatur
baschar al assad
der hat seine gegner im bürgerkrieg
zurück gedrängt doch er herrschte über
ein in weiten teilen verwüstet das land
zunächst informationen von anselm stern
zerstörung leid und hunger das ist der
alltag für viele in syrien unterernährte
kinder kampf ums überleben laut uno
brauchen etwa 13 millionen menschen
dringend hilfe
sie können sich kein essen mehr leisten
die preise sind enorm gestiegen ergebnis
von mehr als zehn jahren bürgerkrieg
seit 2011 dauern die blutigen kämpfe
bereits an mehr als 500.000 menschen
wurden getötet oder werden vermisst
schätzungsweise bis jetzt mehr als zwölf
millionen syrer sind geflohen aus oder
in den zerrissenen land die sogenannten
rebellen darunter auch radikale
islamisten halten noch gebiete etwa in
idlib im norden sind türkische milizen
im nordosten die kurdengebiete etwa zwei
drittel aber kontrollieren wieder die
syrischen regierungstruppen die soldaten
von baschar al-assad unterstützt durch
iran und russland so bleibt der
herrscher in der mascus weiter an der
macht
die menschen in syrien sind heute also
aufgerufen an die wahlurnen zu treten
de facto können aber in dem
bürgerkriegsland viele gar nicht
abstimmen und alle anderen haben nur auf
dem papier eine freie wahl
neben machthaber assad wurden lediglich
zwei chancen lose kandidaten zugelassen
ein ex-minister und ein rechtsanwalt als
unfrei und betrügerisch bewerten die uno
und zahlreiche staaten weltweit die
abstimmung
uli gack berichtet schwer einzuschätzen
und diese begeisterung echt oder
gespielt ist jedenfalls skandieren sie
es gibt nur drei dinge auf dieser welt
syrien baschar al assad
natürlich will ich assad er war der
steuermann auf rauer see während einer
internationalen verschwörung gegen
syrien
so reden viele in damaskus es wird
allgemein erwartet dass man an der wahl
teilnimmt offen wie hier millionen die
nicht im herrschaftsbereich ersatz leben
sind von der wahl ausgeschlossen kritik
von westlichen außenminister die diese
wahl als weder frei noch fair beurteilen
wischt präsident assad heute beiseite
die westliche meinung zeit bedeutungslos
meinte er
ebenso deren werte zehn tage hatte
mahmud marei zeit sich auf seinen
wahlkampf vorzubereiten einer von zwei
handverlesenen kandidaten die gegen
assad antreten dürfen eine chance hat er
nichts sagt er aber ein programm
ich wehre mich für eine neue verfassung
einsetzen dazu eine gewaltenteilung
erarbeiten und mich um die freilassung
der politischen gefangenen kümmern
mai ist in den personenkult um assad
kaum zu finden der präsident dagegen ist
um präsent 210 kandidaten sollen dieser
wahl einen demokratischen anstrich geben
mit hoher wahlbeteiligung und
prognostiziert 90 prozent stimmen auf
bascha al-assad will er sich als alter
und neuer präsident aber auch als
internationaler verhandlungspartner
legitimieren so das kalkül aus damaskus
viele in syrien haben andere probleme
millionen sind von hunger bedroht so die
un und es werden immer mehr
wir erleben kinder und jugendliche den
konflikt in syrien auf zdf heute und in
unserer app erzählen der 14 jahre alte
hassan und die 12 jährige maler von
ihrem alltag in einem syrischen
zeltlager und davon wie sie wieder
hoffnung schöpfen
indien leidet unter der krise und nun
kämpfen die menschen zusätzlich mit den
folgen eines schweren tropensturms
heftigen niederschläge und bis zu vier
meter hoch gepeitschte wellen setzten
ganze regionen unter wasser betroffen
sind rund 10 millionen
wie groß die zerstörungen bisher sind
ist noch unklar
tja wir sind beim sport und nun zur
eishockey-wm und zur ersten deutschen
niederlage an arbeit nach drei siegen in
folge der gegner heute favoritenschreck
kasachstan und der gewann in einem
spannenden spiel knapp mit 3 zu 2 ein
rückschlag für das dbb team im kampf um
den einzug ins viertelfinale
große enttäuschung für das team von
trainer toni süderholz seine mannschaft
zwar überlegen und einsatzfreudig aber
mit schlechter chancenverwertung
die 2 1-führung durch den mannheimer
markus eisenschmidt kurz vor ende des
zweiten drittels gibt deutschland noch
aus der hand
aufsteiger kasachstan clever in der
defensive und mit großer effektivität in
der offensive star schenker mit einem
penalty zum 2 2 und 4 minuten vor der
schlusssirene das 3 2 pavel alkohol
ziehen besiegelt die erste deutsche
wm-niederlage zwei fußball personalien
nach präsident fritz keller hat nun auch
dfb generalsekretär friedrich kurz muss
seinen posten wie angekündigt geräumt
als konsequenz aus dem internen
führungsstreit und die trainerbank beim
vfl wolfsburg kommt oliver glasner r
wechselt als nachfolger von eintracht
coach adi hütter nach frankfurt heute
abend rollt der fußball das
relegations-hinspiel zwischen den ersten
fc köln und holstein kiel und 23 15 die
zusammenfassung hier bei uns im zdf ja
und in danzig das finale der fußball-
europa-league villarreal gegen
manchester united die briten gelten als
favoriten die außenseiter aus spanien
könnten ihren ersten internationalen
titel holen große vorfreude bei den fans
vom fc villarreal für die spanier ist
bereits der einzug in das finale der
euroleague an meilenstein in der fast
hundertjährigen vereinsgeschichte
in seinem ersten großen endspiel will
sich der spanische tabellen 17 nicht
verstecken
wir wollen die geschichte weiter führen
mit dem finale ein neues vereins kapitel
schreiben
[Musik]
auch manchester united möchte seiner
ruhmreichen historie einen weiteren
titel hinzufügen das team von ole gunnar
solskjaer ist
rekordmeister hat die premier league
saison gerade als tabellenzweiter
abgeschlossen
maximal 9500 zuschauer sind heute abend
zugelassen verteilen sich und ihre
sympathien im weiten rund des stadions
in danzig und das was vom sport danke
norbert und wir haben noch die
lottozahlen
sie lauten 2 23 34 35 44 46 und die
superzahl 7 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf
text auf seite 55 74 tagen habe ich noch
ein paar zahlen für dich und zwar die 32
32 jahre hast du insgesamt fürs zdf
gearbeitet und die 3 6 6 1 das ist deine
3661 die heute -sendung dido moderiert
hast deine letzte ich habe es genau
nachrechnet sich lage noch nahe steht
jetzt gehst du in ruhestand und im lotto
bild zu bleiben
ein riesengewinn für deinen mann ein
riesenverlust für uns aber wir haben so
ein kleines filmisches dankeschön
vorbereitet
meine damen und herren erfreuliche
nachrichten
sie moderiert und moderiert und
moderiert vertraut und verlässlich punkt
19 uhr nachrichten mit petra gerster
seit 1998
wobei los ging's noch früher
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei dieser ausgabe
von ml mona lisa 1989 tv von frauen für
alle für gleichberechtigung aber gegen
mekka und patriarchen fürs engagement
gibt es preise für alles was kommt ein
anliegen
ich habe schon versucht in den
nachrichten frauen immer auch mit zur
sprache zu bringen
erstens thematisch mädchen frauenrechte
die rechte benachteiligter generell und
zweitens sprachlich beim gendern mit
sternchen ging sie mit voran gerne
folgte mann und frau petra gerster auf
reisen durch die virtuelle welt durch
die reale auf vielen reportagen
natürlich auch
und klar durch reisen in die welt der
politik ebenfalls und gut folgte man ihr
auch weil die sprache prägnant und gut
ist sagen sie dieser ort sie sind in
seogwipo entscheidung war einfach also
ich das nicht lieber sagen immer
charmant immer elegant nachrichtliche
distanz und menschliche nähe eine frau
der man vertraut das zdf sagt ganz
lieben dank
[Musik]
danke für die tolle arbeit danke für die
schnelle zeiten seinen blumenstrauß
kolleginnen und kolleginnen also von
einer korrektur
vielen dank dank jetzt so das war jetzt
sehr überraschend liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer
das war's für mich fast 23 jahre lang
durfte ich sie an dieser stelle mit den
nachrichten des tages versorgen heute
zum letzten mal
ich danke ihnen von herzen für das
vertrauen das sie mir und allen die an
dieser sendung beteiligt sind
entgegengebracht haben die wichtigste
voraussetzung für unsere arbeit
das heute t macht weiter genauso
sorgfältig und engagiert wie immer ich
verabschiede mich heute ausnahmsweise
mal einen fußball philosophen zitierend
in früheren eintracht frankfurt trainer
stepanovic genannter tpm geht weiter
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein letztes tief
mit kaltluft erreicht uns und bringt uns
noch einmal schauer und gewitter und
teilweise kräftigen regen an den alpen
hier mit der kaltfront aber dieses hoch
hier über dem nordatlantik dehnt sich
aus und wird zum wochenende dann die
erwärmung bringen in der nacht
allerdings gibt es noch viele wolken im
nordwesten hier einziehen
regen und gewitter sind dabei und auch
im süden regnet es kräftig und das bei
tiefsten temperaturen von fünf grad im
vogtland und 10 grad am niederrhein
morgen im tagesverlauf ziehen die
schauer und gewitter weiter südwärts
ganz an den alpen da schaut es auch
dazwischen etwas sonnenschein mit
temperaturen von 19 grad im südwesten
und 11 grad im vogtland und die nächsten
tage werden allmählich sonniger von
westen her nur im norden am freitag
schauer 14 bis 21 grad und vor allem am
sonntag wärmer bis 23 grad
ein schöner abend